[Musique]
nous sommes le 10 janvier 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités l'émission consacrée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité du
département yvelinois voici les titres
l'île de france présente son budget pour
2010 est mal gré et des ressources en
chute les investissements seront
renforcés c'est ce que nous expliquera
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
c'est un partenaire incontournable du
paris-nice le département vers une
nouvelle fois la compétition cycliste
s'est lancé en ses terres cette fois ci
depuis la ville de bois d'arcy entretien
avec pierre bédier président à des
yvelines investissements en hausse
dépenses de fonctionnement en baisse la
région ile de france présentait tir à la
presse son budget pour l'année 2010 est
des efforts financiers importants sont
notamment consentis dans les transports
et des lycées franciliens
les précisions sur ce budget avec
valérie pécresse donc la présidente
l est républicain de la région elle
était au micro de nikola kirilow huit
panneaux pécresse vous avez présenté le
budget 2010 est 5,5 milliards d'euros
c'est votre on peut dire votre premier
budget qui est marquée de votre saut à
vous puisque l'an passé vous étiez
peut-être encore en mode découverte on
va dire des de la région en tout cas des
finances là c'est votre premier vrai
budget 100% valérie claisse c'est vrai
en même temps l'année dernière c'est
vrai qu'il y avait des idées qui seront
l'appel des coûts partie donc des
dépenses que j'étais obligé d'honorer
mais en même temps dès l'année dernière
nous avions donné le ton on avait
commencé par faire moins 5 % de dépenses
de fonctionnement donc des économies et
+ 5 % dans les dépenses d'investissement
mais cette année évidemment on amplifie
un prêt de 18 % de hausse des
investissements et on baisse encore de
4% le fonctionnement donc nous sommes la
région la plus économe de france 223
millions d'économies et cet argent est
bien on le remet sur les transports qui
sont la priorité absolue des franciliens
on le remet sur le développement
économique qui nous a été transférée qui
était une compétence des départements
qui maintenant devient une compétence
exclusive de la région on le met aussi
sur les lices
et qui sont dans une situation
catastrophique et on n'oublie pas
l'environnement avec des dispositifs
plébiscité le fond propreté le font pour
le remplacement des vieilles chaudières
bois polluantes l'aide aux artisans qui
veulent changer leur véhicule polluant
donc beaucoup de dimension
environnementale dans ce budget est
enfin la culture et le sport des
domaines dans lesquels les villes n'ont
plus les moyens d'investir et dans
lesquels on veut les aider
vous disiez 18% endosse d'investissement
est ce que toutes ces investissements
sont financés grâce à la baisse des
dépenses de fonctionnement ou alors il
faut trouver d'autres moyens de
retrouver d'autres ressources fiscales
non il n'ya pas de hausses d'impôts dans
le budget de la région cette année
en revanche nous avons obtenu parce que
nous sommes allés négocier pied à pied
180 millions d'euros de crédits
européens et je tiens d'ailleurs à
saluer l'action de pierre lequiller il
ya deux ans la région avaient été
chercher 20 millions d'euros de crédits
européens cette année ce sera 180
millions d'euros
et c'est crédible on va pouvoir les
dépensés pour les franciliens et les
aider dans leurs projets donc c'est
énorme c'est 180 millions pareil j'ai
été faire une
enfin une négociation avec le
gouvernement pour effectivement qu'on
ait des nouvelles ressources pour faire
face à la compétence développement
économique des départements qui nous est
transféré et pour faire face aussi à à
nos besoins d'équipement donc on nous
avons eu quelques ressources fiscales
qui ont été transférées par l'état
forcément une grande part de ces
investissements est destiné au transport
pour les pros ceux de la grande couronne
par exemple comme les habitants des
yvelines
qu'est ce que ça implique une
accélération de la mise en place du plan
mis le bus d'abord un milliard d'euros
pour ' 'le pardon du peu mais ma
première décision ça a été de enfin
déboucler financement d'une
infrastructure qui est clé décisive pour
les yvelines parce que écoles de saint
lazare jusqu'à mantes la jolie
c'est non seulement un rer nouvelle
génération avec du matériel neuf
exceptionnel mais c'est aussi le
désengorgement du rer a pour l'ensemble
des habitants de la vallée de la seine
et du saint germanois donc le sujet des
hommes étaient majeurs il manquait deux
cents millions d'euros pour le déboucler
la région a pris ses responsabilités on
a fait le choix des hommes parce que
c'est un choix pour toute l'île de
france
y compris pour les seine et marne et qui
vont travailler à la défense donc et
hall
le plan anti bush ont là aussi la
précédente majorité ne voulait pas
financer les routes nous avons débloqué
27 millions d'euros pour enterrer la
rn10 à trappes vous savez que ça fait
des années et des années que tu rappes
attendait qu'on cicatrise le tissu
urbain
c'était vraiment prioritaire et on va
continuer puisque je me suis engagé
auprès des élus revinois à ce que
évidemment le plan route dans les
yvelines soit majeur et puis à la
tangentielle ouest qui arrive saint cyr
saint germain là aussi attendu depuis 20
ans une dernière question très
rapidement vous parliez d'une situation
catastrophique dans les lycées qu'est ce
que ça veut dire une situation
catastrophique dans l'est dans les
lycées franciliens et ben ça veut dire
qu'on a plusieurs dizaines de lycées en
ile-de-france qui sont dans une
situation de vétusté très préoccupante
et donc il faut trouver pour chacun
d'entre eux des solutions et puis par
ailleurs c'était difficile évidemment de
le prévoir non je plaisante mais les
enfants du baby boom de 2000 2001 2002
2003 arrive aujourd'hui au lycée et donc
on va avoir besoin de créer dix mille
places supplémentaires sinon les enfants
seront accueillis dans des algeco donc
il faut créer des places de lycée donc
il faut construire et nous allons seront
en mars un grand plan d'urgence sur
toute la région
très bien merci beaucoup c'est officiel
la course cycliste paris nice va
s'élancer le 5 mars prochain du
département des yvelines pour la
septième année consécutive pour cette
édition 2010 est bois d'arcy et
rochefort en yvelines ont été
sélectionnées pour accueillir les 22
équipes cyclistes notre journaliste
michael et demi d'euros est allé
rencontrer le président du département
pour en savoir plus je suis avec eux
pierre bédier pour parler du paris nice
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'était la
présentation officielle du parcours pour
2017 alors pierre bédier
cette année une nouvelle fois le
paris-nice partira des yvelines pour la
septième année consécutive septième
année consécutive 75e édition
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi je pense qu'il
faut des baptisés le paris-nice et
d'appeler le yvelines hisse désormais
d'autant qu'on va refaire une convention
pour les quatre années qui viennent donc
2018 2019 2020 2021 c'est un événement
très important pour nous on est un
département de grande pratique cycliste
à la fois d'ailleurs amateurs et
professionnels je rappelle que nous
avons à saint quentin en yvelines le
vélodrome nationale qui accueillera
peut-être les jeux olympiques si paris
est olympique en 2024
donc ce lien très singulier très fort
entre le département des yvelines et la
petite reine comme on appelle là le vélo
et bien ça se symbolise ça se
cristallise à l'occasion du paris nice
deux étapes dans les yvelines s'avoue
satisfait bien sûr ça nous satisfait
parce que c'est une façon pour nous à
travers de merveilleuses images tournées
par les moyens importants d'un de vos
confrères
ça nous permet de valoriser pour la
france entière et au delà de la france
ceux d'ailleurs les images de notre
département des yvelines
et puis c'est aussi des retombées
économiques importantes parce que il ya
des nuitées d'hôtel de la restauration
et puis enfin il ya toute cette
animation populaire le samedi dans les
mairies qui accueille les départs on
organise des manifestations autour du
vélo auquel participent à la population
choisir bois d'arcy comme ville de
départ du paris nice est un bon choix
selon nous c'est même un excellent choix
si je disais le contraire sont mère m'en
voudrez mais c'est un choix qui est
dicté par le fait que le sport est une
priorité municipale très importante et
il ya d'ailleurs de nombreux équipements
une grande pratique sportive dans cette
commune et c'est ce qui a expliqué ce
choix il y aura encore des paris-nice
qui partiront des yvelines dans les
années à venir
oui donc 2018 2019 2020 2021 je ne vous
donnerai pas encore les villes de départ
même si j'ai une petite idée
au moins pour l'année prochaine donc il
y aura au minimum huit étapes
supplémentaires en est divine on peut le
penser et vous et vous serez justement
au départ de bois d'arcy de 5,9 le 5
mars prochain
si vous pensez que je fais le paris-nice
la réponse est négative ce doit être
très agréable je ne pense pas avoir la
condition pour mais où j'essaierai en
fonction du calendrier qui va être un
peu chargé en 2017 pour les élus vous
savez il ya une petite élection au mois
de mai qui va pas mal nous occuper
autrement oui je devrais être au départ
de du paris nice afin du bois d'arcy
nice pour voir pierre bédier
si on les bords de la route et les
cyclistes du paris nice ce sera le 5
mars depuis à bois d'arcy et c'est ainsi
que nous refermons ce 7,8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous le 11
janvier excellente soirée et sur
téléfilm n'oubliez pas les replays sur
notre site internet
[Musique]